bonjour année en classe animals merci
merci merci des cadeaux pour une
occasion pour anne-marie crous cette
ouverture de portail est très
particulière c'est sa dernière la
directrice de l'école primaire de
lavilledieu à elancourt pour sa retraite
cette dernière année je les très très
bien vécu j'en ai vraiment profité
et j'ai une glace très très sympathique
nous avons plein de projets ensemble
c'est un métier alors moi je veux une
façon très particulière c'est à dire que
quand j'y suis
quand je suis avec mes élèves quand je
suis dans mon école je n'ai pas
l'impression de travailler
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui me pèse
après une carrière dans le secteur privé
puis dans un lycée anne marie cruise se
dirige vers l'élémentaire c'est en 2006
qu'elle est amené à diriger cette école
de 240 élèves
après s'être longtemps occupé des cp
elle termine sa carrière avec des cm1
cm1 je les adore et j'espère qu'elle
reviendra un jour peut-être temps écoles
elle était gentille fois elle gronde et
ce qu'ils ne portaient pas le scénario
est très gentil quand il fallait
le type est trop gentil et j'étais très
sympa cette année on a appris beaucoup
de choses elle était très gentille je
l'approuvé stricte aussi j'aime bien et
je trouve c'est une très bonne maîtresse
32 ans d'enseignement 18 c comme
directrice depuis le 6 juillet anne
marie cruz à fermer ce chapitre de sa
carrière professionnelle les élèves eux
sont partis pour deux mois de vacances